receiver allen robinson one of the guys
entering a contract here shireen who
didn't get a long-term deal now
fully and officially disgruntled and
reportedly has asked for a trade out of
town as he gets one game into what is
the final year of that deal your
reaction to alan robinson wanting out
supposedly
well you know ryan pace the general
manager of the bears said last week that
there was no deadline on these deals but
the bears typically as most teams do get
their long term deals with their core
players wrapped up before the season
opener now here we are past the season
opener in week two and he still doesn't
have his deal and it tells you that they
haven't made extensive negotiations
progress on negotiations
and so he has asked for a trade
according to brad biggs of the chicago
tribune and is looking to get out
who knows where this goes at this point
but he scrubbed all mention of the bears
from his social media and is obviously
not happy with what's going on these
things tend to get worked out one way or
the other whether that means a trade or
whether that means a long-term deal it's
probably going to get worked out one of
those ways
i think we can say football season
officially has begun when a player
scrubs all mention of his team from his
social media accounts and every time i
even think that much less writers say it
i realize how trite and superficial that
is but that's how people send messages
nowadays what they allow onto their
social media page what's on their
profile what's in their background what
they are wearing all of that stuff shows
how they feel and if you take all
references to the bears off your social
media page and you're a member of the
bears that may mean that you'll want out
last year 98 catches a career high for
alan robinson
1147 yards and seven touchdowns he's
still yet to live up to
the standard he set in his second year
in jacksonville in 2015 but a lot of
that was garbage time production all due
respect that was the year that we let
ourselves think blake bortles is a good
quarterback
uh they were behind they threw the ball
they gained a lot of yardage that way i
think alan hearns also had a thousand
receiving yards that year in 2015 if not
a thousand close to it but since then
883 2017 he had 17 after he suffered a
week one torn acl 754 his first year in
chicago he's now climbed back to 11 47.
i can see why he wants to get paid and
you know when you see
a guy like marlon mack in indy in a
contract year shireen suffer a torn
achilles tendon and he's done for the
year after one week and when your
personal history in the nfl includes a
week one acl tear you know what the risk
is and you know what can happen and his
market goes goes out the window if he
suffers an injury that ends his season
and sends him on to the free agent
market while he's recovering from some
sort of a season-ending injury so i
understand why he wants his deal
no question about it he's making 10.9
million this year and he looked at what
keenan allen got there have been
obviously a lot of receiver contracts
that we've seen this off season but
keenan allen compares favorably keenan
allen's played one more year than alan
robinson has but if you observe their
stats they're they're pretty darn close
to what they've done in fact alan
robinson has only won fewer touchdowns
than keenan robertson than kenyon allen
does despite paint playing one fewer
years and i would argue that alan
robinson has not played with very many
good quarterbacks if any good
quarterbacks in his career as you said
blake bortles and now he's with mitchell
trubisky so he hasn't played with a
really good quarterback he's only 27.
somebody's gonna want him whether it's
now in a trade whether it's after this
season with a big contract if they can't
get the extension done somebody is going
to want alan robinson is he worth 20
million a year i think that's what the
bears probably are grappling with at
this point is he worth that and i'm not
sure he is but that's what the market
bears
and i think part of the challenge when
you pay a receiver big money is having
the confidence that you will have a
quarterback who can allow you to get the
return on your investment that has to be
part of this they don't know who their
quarterback is going to be next year
their starter mitchell trubisky's in the
last year of his contract why because
they didn't pick up the fifth year
option why because he stunk last year
and to consider that alan robinson got
1147 receiving yards in a year where
mitchell trubisky played like crap i
think we can say crap at 5 p.m eastern
time we definitely can say it at 11 p.m
local time in the uk we have done the
research crap is acceptable then i it
really creates a conundrum for the bears
on what they're going to do because
who's the quarterback going to be and
what kind of production are you going to
get and do you really
get the bang for your buck if you give
this guy big money was last year a fluke
that's the thing he's got two full
seasons with the bears 754 in the year
the team was good 11 47 in the year at a
team was bad what do you really get for
this guy over the long haul
well and the question for the bears is
what's going to happen after this year
as you said with the quarterback but
with the gm with the coach with
everything else this is a a team with a
roster that's very much in flux heading
into next year and a lot depends
obviously on how they do this year
they need a happy and healthy allen
robinson if they're going to do what
they think they can do which is
duplicate a couple years ago when they
got to the playoffs and they were a
really good football team but they need
allen robinson they need him to be happy
if that's going to happen so they're
they're to me they're they're really in
a bad spot with how much to give him
what the future looks like especially
with the salary cap going forward
and how much he means to your football
team and he means a lot this year but
he's mean a lot next year and the year
after especially if there's a new coach
a new quarterback and and all that new
stuff that teams go through when they
don't win so they're in a tough spot
right now they didn't get this done when
they probably should have gotten it done
which was before keenan allen got his
deal done
and here's the reality you know we see
this every year players want out
sometimes they get out sometimes they
don't sometimes the team says there's no
way in hell we're letting the guy out
and then they let him out it all depends
upon
what gets offered to the chicago bears
for alan robinson a former jaguars
player and we've seen a couple of
jaguars players who wanted out and the
team said we're not letting you go but
then when you get two ones and a four
for jalen ramsey or a second round pick
plus for yannick and gawkway that's when
you say yes and that may be what the
bears ultimately do and i think part of
it is you sit and you wait for the
season to shake out and if it means alan
robinson has an injury or an injury that
keeps him from playing until he's traded
whatever the case may be
because if muhammad sunu is going to
generate a second round pick last year
and emanuel sanders is going to generate
a third round pick last year what can
you get for an allen robinson this year
it could be the market corrects and that
teams say holy crap what were the
patriots and the 49ers thinking
respectively last year for what they
gave up for sunu and and sanders the
other argument is the market's been set
you want a receiver who's going to be
the proverbial final piece to your
puzzle you're trying to go all in to
make a championship run we got a guy
that could potentially help you out and
i think that's part of the reason why
the bears need to play this cool not
give in now because it could be if they
wait a few weeks the value goes up
yeah no question you have injuries at
the receiver position and everything
else that that goes on there and teams
are going to be looking for receivers i
immediately though you talked about last
year the patriots trading for sunu and
the 49ers also looked at sunu before
getting emmanuel sanders i look at the
patriots and say could they use an allen
robinson absolutely they could so that
might be a team that you you look at in
a few weeks the bears make a phone call
and say hey what are you willing to give
us for alan robinson he's much better
player than muhammad sanu was can you
give us more than you gave for muhammad
sanew last year so
that would be a team you look at right
away but there are going to be some
receiver injuries and some places that
that alan robinson can go if the bears
don't want to give him what he wants
yeah whether it's injuries in the short
term or whether it's that team that
wants to go all in as the trade deadline
arrives there is some flexibility there
i think the question becomes how
extensively will robinson be used by the
bears once he's made it clear that he
wants out will they find a way to keep
him off the field like jalen ramsey got
several weeks off last year while the
jaguars were figuring out what to do
with him and
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports